foreign
are you hearing what you're saying I
think that I've tried to convince myself
that it's not that bad it's it's getting
too too scary Brittany get out
[Music]
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
show is here for helping you change your
marriage helping you change your life
helping to change your Fitness and
Nutrition and your mental health how to
be a better parent that's what we're
doing here on the show and man I'm so
grateful that you're with us if you want
to be on this show talk about what's
going on in your life
um how you can make the next right
choice give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John delaney.com
ask and right off the top if you are
struggling with
you've been married 10 years and you
feel like you are six inches apart six
thousand miles away from your spouse if
you are staring at your kids and you're
like who are you
go to John deloney.com and pick up
questions for humans there's a million
different decks there's decks for work
there's decks there's a couple of four
couples there's one for dating there's
one for kids pick up questions for
humans and sit down and begin to
re-engage with your family the season of
screens obsession is over this the
season that athletic Tick Tock parent
your kids it's over it's over go pick up
questions for humans and let's start
reclaiming our homes and our mental
health and our marriages all of it let's
do it all right let's go out to Toledo
Ohio and talk to Brittany what's up
Brittany how we doing
good how are you partying man what are
you up to
that's not true
lunch break early lunch yeah
I was gonna say your boss is the worst
but this is like a late breakfast break
but let's go hey whatever whatever works
what's happening how are you
good I am excited to hear um
iel
um I think that physical abuse is in my
future from my husband
and my question is how can I get get my
husband to get professional help
when I also you know kind of fear Him
and I'm afraid to make him angry in that
encouragement to do that
did you did you write this question down
before you called I did practice it out
loud okay when you practiced it
did it feel insane as it came out of
your mouth
and I mean that like in a fun way like I
mean not like you know I'm pointing at
you but like in a are you hearing what
you're saying
this phone call is very difficult for me
to make okay because
I think that I've tried to convince
myself that it's not that bad but I made
myself Journal after this last fight
because I didn't want to forget like
it's it's getting too too scary Brittany
get out
I'm hey and listen you know me I'm
always laughing carrying on you got to
get out
what you are saying is I'm about to be
assaulted I'm about to be abused
what can I do
what what is one story I can finally
tell him what is one thing in the
bedroom I can finally what's one thing I
can do
so that this person doesn't do a highly
irrational
illegal act
against a violence against me and the
answer is nothing get out
you gotta get out
why does that sound insane to you
I
it's it sounds crazy because I have seen
progress in our marriage
um but this last fight scared you
yeah yeah
so there's not progress you're telling
yourself stories why
yeah why
are you scared of what's on the other
side are you scared of being alone what
are you scared of
I and it's okay to be scared of all that
stuff right
um we are very
committed Christ followers I disagree I
a hundred percent disagree
I don't believe you
yeah because Christ followers don't beat
their wives
yeah they don't they take a knee
all right they go get help
right and so you've got a bunch of
different voices you've got your church
barking in your ear you've got
knuckleheaded friends who just keep
repeating things that should be stitched
on pillows to you you've got misguided
devotional guy whatever
you gotta get out you're worth being
safe
home should be a place where you get off
your after your early lunch break and
you go back to whatever job you're doing
you go home
and you you're you're you're you smile
as you walk in the door because it's
such a safe warm place
even if it hasn't happened yes
yeah
at some point you gotta stop blaming
yourself you got to stop coming up with
stories to defend this guy
right absolutely not a Christ follower
and I would say that if he was sitting
right here in front of me
he's using that as cover to do whatever
he wants to do in your life
what are you scared of
I'm being serious I'm being serious
because I want to do it I want to do
what I can in this short call to pull to
pull right to shine some light on that
fear and let you know that it's probably
toothless
I I guess I I just think I thought that
there was
something that could be
like fixed on his end because it's not
there can be but he's got to do the work
yeah you can't do anything this is
who he is I think it's an ability that
he's able to get to no no no
um Brittany
stop defending him
stop
you've been defending him to your
friends and you've been defending him to
your family for a long time it doesn't
work with me stop
yeah
any man
who has a wife
who is in
believes that she can be physically
injured at any moment
is not a person of character
all right
period
and I've expressed this to him uh like
my fear I've told him like you know this
is the path that it looks like it's
going down
of course any person in that situation
would say I never want to do that so
um and he did and I like and I've
created has he hit you
no no how close has he got
just our fights have gotten to the point
where it's
has he hit the wall by you
right
or like broken things you know or like
get out
until he stops acting like a
nine-year-old on a bus stop
get out yeah
you've got to be safe Brittany because
here's why you're not gonna sleep
yeah your body's not gonna let you
because it's trying to stay safe it's
trying to not die
and you've Pro how long have you been
with this dude
five years
and how long did you date before that
two so by now in these situations you
are highly isolated true or false
say it it's just innocence but but I I
have surrounded myself with good people
I'm not do they know
like one
okay
you are completely alone in this deal
it is what happens this is what happens
it's a common story it's a common
refrain you start protecting yourself
and eventually your friends say I can't
be a part of this or there's something
about this dude that I don't like and
you get mad at them or they get mad at
you and you begin to slowly that that
circle of influence gets Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter
and I don't know you you could walk into
this room right now and I wouldn't know
because I've never seen you I have no
idea who this person is but I've heard
this story too much
and when I say get out that doesn't mean
forever
what that means is you have the only
thing on planet Earth you can control is
your thoughts and your actions that's it
true and your actions right now are to
be safe and you are not safe in your own
bed you're not safe in your own living
room you're not safe in your own kitchen
You're Not Safe in your own home get out
find a place where you can be safe
yeah and then he and only he has some
significant choices about the therapy
he's gonna go get
right about the
um mentorship he's gonna get he's gonna
have to deal with his addictions because
I guarantee you he's got some guaranteed
he's got to deal with his anger he's
gonna have to deal with his childhood
mess he's got to deal with all of it
and listen to me super carefully I
absolutely one thousand percent do not
care what he does or doesn't want to do
I care what he does
right
I've talked to I've
I've never met somebody who wants to hit
their wife
but they're right but they do
get out okay and I tell you that because
I love you and if he was sitting right
here right next to me I would tell him
your wife needs to go away while you get
safe
um
and if he wants to call me I would love
to talk to him not in a mean Macho way
but just like I I don't think he wants
to be the guy he is but
Brittany he is the guy he is
okay
will you get will you commit just just
on this call will you commit
finding a way to be safe go stay with a
girlfriend for two or three or four
weeks
it's usually a minimum of 30 days all
right
because it's not it I mean you're saying
something that I haven't thought about
but like it's not up to me no to like
encourage him no you get get the help no
right
a murder victim doesn't encourage her
murderer to stop murdering right that's
not right
he or she has to decide to not murder
right
because listen I want you to follow this
track when you say there's not anything
I can do to encourage him what you're
doing is you are saying this abuse him
smashing the wall behind my head him
throwing crap across the house and
throwing it at me getting really close
put making a fist and balling it up
right by my face
put his hand on my neck those things are
somehow your fault
because you need some encouragement and
it's not
right
and he can wrap himself up and you just
make me so mad he can wrap himself up in
his little Jesus flag and he can wrap
himself up and whatever crap he wants to
wrap himself up in
he's a guy that's terrifying his wife
with physical violence
right you my friend Brittany I want you
to be safe
so that that's the call
only thing you can control are your
thoughts and your actions and I want you
to think about what it's going to take
for Brittany to be safe for a season and
it's probably going to take a minimum of
30 days for of you leaving and getting a
safe place to stay
and I know that for millions of people
in this country they have got a friend
or a family member they can go has a
spare room and millions and millions and
millions of people in this country have
nowhere to go maybe a French couch for
30 days
maybe another apartment that they can
scratch up enough pennies and nickels to
to sign a 30-day lease
and it's sketchy and scary and I know
all that it's terrifying
or maybe it's you get with your employer
and you get your with your employee
assistance program and you go talk to a
counselor and say I'm terrified for my
life is there any Community Resources in
my community where I live right now
but you gotta stay safe and then you be
very clear to him here is my guidelines
for staying in relationship with you
ever threatened to hit me again it's
over I'm out if you ever ball your fist
up or smash something in this house I'm
out
if you ever scream and yell at me I'm
out if you swear at me I'm out if you
cheat on me again I'm out
because the out that's what you can
control all this other nonsense is what
he can control
you're worth being safe and you're worth
a loving warm relationship and you're
worth way more than what he's given you
right now
[Music]
choose safety
choose safety choose safety
we'll be right back
hey deloney here folks getting out of
debt and getting good sleep have
something in common intentionality when
you're working your way out of debt you
have to be purposeful you got to build
your emergency fund pay off your debt
smallest to largest and stick with it
all that stuff and when you're ready to
invest in good sleep you have to have a
plan too you gotta get that early
morning sunlight you gotta exercise you
gotta cut out all this caffeine and you
gotta limit screen time and you have to
budget for a premium quality mattress
because it makes an enormous difference
and that's why I recommend dream Cloud
mattresses and for my friends on a
budget I have incredible news right now
dream cloud is offering my listeners 25
off their order plus 50 in additional
savings and why not 599 more dollars in
accessories with promo code John deloney
that's pillows luxury sheets and a
mattress protector and dream Cloud gives
you a one-year in-home trial so you can
make sure it's the right right fit so
it's time to invest in good sleep have a
budget meeting with your spouse make a
plan and then go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney to get your
new mattress today that's
dreamcloudsleep.com and use code John
deloney
all right let's go to Nicole in Cypress
what's up Nicole how we doing
hi Dr deloney
how's it going
I'm good how are you good good good good
what's up
um so when I initially wrote in it was
um titled like single mother with no
Village
um I guess I struggle a lot I have a
three-year-old and a two-year-old okay
and their dad is not in the picture he
we decided on starting a family and then
I guess once my son was born about three
months into it I found out that
it was being unfaithful so you know that
was right before that was actually right
before the pandemic started so then we
were stuck inside a one-bedroom
apartment with a newborn and just
nowhere to go because it was a big
shutdown over here in California well
everywhere but you know where I am but a
lot in California yeah yeah so
um
it was hard and I guess since then you
know it's
I think we try to like kind of make it
work and everything and then it didn't
so we separated ways and ever since we
have not lived together which was in
um
I get little less and less support from
him and then I guess it's just become
more and more toxic because I think he
just walks in and out whenever he wants
so is there no is there no custody
Arrangement did y'all go to court
we didn't
um okay you need to do that
I know and I know you don't want to but
you need to do that and and if even if
you don't think enough of yourself to do
it for you in your safety in your
um Economic Security down the road
if you're kids
yeah you know for your kids
so I guess like I struggle because
and I I have them like 99 of the time he
sees them a few hours a couple days a
week
um until it's a season where he decides
he wants to show up and be more frequent
um but most of the time listen that's
destroying those kids
I know stop
yeah
do you are you still intimate with him
you still sleep with him every once in a
while
no
um when's the last time you are together
um like intimately was
um maybe last summer because he said he
wanted to try no no you don't you don't
get me because you don't think because
I'm not trying to do it to shame you I'm
trying to
I'm trying to at some point you're
getting something out of this too
and it's not sexually like that there's
this profound loneliness
and this profound you had a picture of
what life was going to be like with two
kids and a family and you all agreed on
it and I don't think you let that
picture go yet and you're still trying
to hang on
and every time he pops in and out of
that picture you're like oh there it is
it could happen it could happen and then
he comes in in the summer and he's like
hey let's make this thing work
and then you feel used and the whole you
see what I'm saying yeah
the picture's over
and what the world and your kids are
desperate for Nicole is for you to to
draw something new
okay
is that is that fair tell me I'm wrong
man tell me you're gonna make this thing
work
no I I mean I have gotten no contact
with him for a while now so it's just
been you know I guess I guess I fear
when he does try to do it you know again
because recently he's
I mean I did file like I had to file a
restraining order
um so you've no contact ordered him like
so you've you've been yeah go through
the paperwork
yeah so yeah and then they just they
just were able to serve him recently for
the child support papers and stuff I
guess the child I mean not child support
yeah child support but not the we
haven't done custody stuff so we all
legally divorced are we all ever legally
married
no we were never legally married okay
okay yeah go to the go go through the
paperwork process and clear some of
these lines up
and when you do that
it's gonna be
so relieving and it's going to be
devastating at the same time and I want
you to expect both of those okay
the relief of
everybody's on the same page now the
chances he pays if you look at the data
across the country are low
okay right the chances that he just
doesn't show up on a Tuesday anyway
you're gonna have to follow those things
to a T
okay follow things to a T I was working
with somebody recently um privately
who's
um
showed up and like whose kids out of
town showed up at night uh the night
before and just called their spouse and
said hey
um can I go ahead and take so and so our
kid out to dinner
I know custody doesn't start I mean I
know my visitation starts in the morning
caused a hole just follow it to a letter
follow it to the letter to the letter to
the letter but you gotta get in writing
you got to get it written down you got
to get a judge to sign off on it
and then there's going to be a finality
because you're going to go look at that
picture at that canvas and it's going to
be completely blank and it's going to be
terrifying
the kids I guess um is what I worry
about the most like Barefoot like you
know they see them you know him the few
hours a week you know twice a week
um and they really enjoy those times and
but it's magic time it's not real
right he gets to play superhero he gets
to show up and give him Chick-fil-A
McDonald's and ice cream and play for a
couple hours and be the cool
rambunctious guy then it gets to
disappear
yeah and you have to do math homework
and you have to do bedtimes and you have
to do bath times so it's it's it's it's
not real time their experiences with him
are
uh I mean they're they're they're a
vapor
I found out because he agreed that he
wouldn't take him to his apartment
because he lives with a male roommate
um you know they're in there I think
he's in his 30 years single um I'm not
saying anything's wrong with that but he
does have like friends over and I just
worry about you know the risk you should
all of it okay listen Nicole somewhere
along the way somebody told you that
that that voice in your guts should just
shut up
and I'm telling you for the for the
first time in a long time you got to
start trusting your gut you gotta listen
to that voice because it knows
it knows you know what's going on in
that apartment Nicole you've known that
dude for a long time
you know
right so
yeah you should you should that's what
I'm telling you go get the paperwork
done
and how are the kids going to be like
it's gonna be hard
but listen he left y'all
he left y'all
and it's going to be worse when they're
in Middle School
and he says things like I don't know man
your mom just took you away and you're
gonna have to deal with that crap too
here's what you're doing you're playing
a 25-year game with them now
are they boy girl what are they
I have a son and daughter okay
a little boy is going to be wondering
what in the world he did to send Dad
away
and that little girl's gonna wonder what
was so beautiful about somebody else
the daddy wanted to be with them and not
mommy and me
mm-hmm
unfortunately those you you
letting him come in and out of your life
is not going to answer those questions
for those kids
it's going to be a long game of you
showing up and showing up and showing up
and showing up and showing up
and when they look back they'll go oh
golly dang dude
but in the in the me in the meantime you
can't expect an 11 year old a
six-year-old a nine-year-old a 15 year
old to not want to go where the cool
stuff's happening
dad's cool roommates and you know what I
mean that's where every kid's gonna want
to go there
that's where they need an adult in their
life that says hey
I love you enough to say no I love you
enough to give you some stability some
safety
and unfortunately dad's not playing that
game
[Applause]
okay and what this also means is you're
gonna have to get some people in your
life
you're gonna have to get a couple of
girlfriends that you trust deeply that
you can email that you can text you can
call that will come over in the middle
of the night that will go out and hang
out with you
you're gonna have to get those folks in
your life you can't do this by yourself
not for not forever
done anything by myself you know for
myself well other than like I guess
shower and I guess get my nails done yes
yes listen you you you you think that's
normal now
and I'm smiling like as though we're
hanging out like I would be laughing and
you would be laughing
you think nine minutes under hot hot
water
is your R and our time
it's not
yeah I know
yeah and maybe no one's ever told you
this but you are worth so much more
and by the way my friend will uh guadera
who's a restaurant here in New York he
tells his staff this when he when he uh
he tells his staff he always is telling
them
his weight staff you cannot fill up
other people's pictures of other
people's glasses if your picture's empty
if you want to really serve your
customers well you got to go in the back
room and fill up your pictures and only
then can you fill up your the the the
customer's glasses same principle
applies to you Mom all you single moms
out there
you can't fill up your little kids
glasses
unless your picture's full and I know
God I know like oh you privileged you're
just I know I know I know it's hard for
me to hear that from me I get that 100
good call up
but I'm telling you
the greatest gift you can give your life
when dad walks out on them is a well Mom
is a mom who believes in herself enough
and loves herself enough to demonstrate
to those kids here's what self-care
looks like here's what love looks like
here's what laughter and joy looks like
y'all are worth those things you're
worth those things Nicole
hang on the line here I'm gonna send you
a copy of my book own your past change
your future I want you to read it once
you do the exercises in it and then I
want you to call me back and we can talk
through here's what we do next here's
where we go from here
[Music]
but I want you to call the courts let's
get this thing in writing let's get the
the custody Arrangement down you've
you've had the no contact order you've
taken care of the child support stuff
let's go ahead and do this all the way
let's get some people in our life in
your life that will walk alongside you
if you don't have anybody it's going to
be awkward and weird he's making friends
as an adult is the worst but you're
worth it
every step of the way call me anytime
Nicole anytime we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I I
fell through a glitch in The Matrix this
is my job I get to have this show do
this show walk alongside each one of you
as a career this is what I do and I have
a blast doing it and me and the team
were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back in it's
everybody's favorite lightning rounds
all right today we're talking about work
and Leadership and I have not seen these
questions and so Kelly is going to let
them R.I.P let him rip all right first
question like she does in the booth all
the time I was kidding that was a fart
joke I'm sorry there it is go ahead all
right first question what are some
qualities that make a great leader
um a leader goes first whether that's
doing the hard thing whether that is uh
being transparent whether that's
um admitting faults that's saying I was
wrong I changed my mind uh a leader
somebody who goes first a leader
somebody who's empathetic and a leader
is somebody who tells the truth and a
leader somebody that holds themselves
and everybody else accountable
nice
nice all right how do I separate my
career and my identity
oh gosh
um your your career is a job
it's it's a it's a way to earn a living
your
um identity is who you are moving
through the world and so the way I would
say that is one of the identities I've
chosen to take is
um I sit with people
uh who are hurting I I sit with
struggling people I did that when I
worked at Burger King I worked at Burger
King for four years worked my way up to
assistant manager what up but I worked
at Burger King
um I also was a dean of students I also
was a professor I also now I'm a
YouTuber for God's sake and in every one
of those jobs my my identity was I sit
with hurting people and lunch rush at
Burger King people are standing in line
exhausted dead-eyed
man it's hurting people all through that
line and people call into the show
people are hurting it's all to the line
so your identity is like who you are why
are you why are you operating in the
world and your job is the way you make
money if you're really really lucky
those two things can can work together
all right as a leader I need to have an
awkward conversation with a direct
report how do I start the conversation
this is going to be an awkward
conversation
I think any other way around that
usually one of two things happens and
I've done both of these incorrectly you
have like a hey how's it going how's the
fam oh yeah how's little Timmy did his
play go well great that's awesome hey
you're fired like there's that way which
is just catches everybody off guard
there's the you walk in and you feel
like it's a funeral you can feel the
weight in there and the you're nervous
as a leader and a boss you're nervous
I'm scared I'm uncomfortable
um that's true too the best way is to
say hey we need to have an uncomfortable
conversation this is going to be awkward
for both of us
um here we go and you do you gotta start
bathing before you I've had that
conversation
um you're gonna have to start putting on
deodorant have that conversation
um I've had all those uh conversations
so it starts with this is gonna be an
awkward conversation and if possible let
me add this this is going to be an
awkward conversation and I need you to
know I'm on your I'm on your team on
this but here's what has to happen
all right my team went to a happy hour
one of them made an inappropriate joke
that made others uncomfortable all right
bro how do I talk to them about it very
just like that
um
just being off-site just being drunk is
not an excuse It's a context right and
so
um if you get drunk and you say stupid
stuff at a bar well those people are
gonna who you're gonna see on Monday and
it goes with you and um not that this
has ever happened to me in my life I've
never gone out and said something
inappropriate and had to look at those
people on Monday ever in my life
um but you have that conversation direct
the same as you would at work because
it's inappropriate it's inappropriate
it's inappropriate
all right
Kelly what that was that was that
somebody put that in for you by the way
no but I always laugh at the Christmas
party every year because there's always
one or two people that you're like man
Monday morning it's gonna be awkward
they gotta come back I remember a few
years ago Joe Levitt was like uh the guy
who who he's worked in the company in
live events for a long time he's he's
institution here he's awesome but he got
up and he goes listen this is a
Christmas party and you gotta know where
I work at Ramsey Solutions Christmas
parties are
they're unfathomable like it's it's it's
chaos it's unbelievable and he said
this is a Christmas party don't lose
your job don't lose your job what do you
do don't you know I mean and I just I
thought what are we doing and then I got
in there I was like oh there's somebody
out there gonna lose your job yeah
there's
yeah there's personal brands that take a
hit that night oh yeah
it's funny a lot of money Kelly
when I took over this show
um how do I own up to what happened
gracefully
you ask your supervisor your leader for
um some time and then you walk you make
sure make sure I've made this mistake
too make sure you have your facts in a
row
and sometime one time that's the whole
other story I'll get into it I've
thought I've made mistakes to the tune
of three quarters of a million dollars
before the spreadsheet error
um and then I thought I've made the
worst mistake it wasn't that big it was
25 000 bucks and over the course of a
multi 100 million dollar company it's
not that big a deal
but you walk in and say I've made a
mistake I screwed something up I made an
error here's what I think the extent of
the damage is and if you've got one or
two ideas here's what I think I can do
to help but I'm open for any questions
you have and so I'm taking ownership of
it as Jocko says extreme ownership I
screwed this up even if you're um like a
mid manager and one of your people
screwed up you're the boss walk in and
say this happened under my watch don't
be one of those leaders it's like hey
this guy did this happened under my
watch one of my staff members did X Y or
Z I'm the leader I'm taking ownership of
it and you might get fired
your integrity is not worth a job you
might get demoted your demotion is not
worth your job like that's not worth
your job go in there and say this is
what happened this is what it cost
here's what I think I can do to help and
often your boss is gonna say God's sakes
don't do anything that your solution is
terrible I got a better solution we'll
work together
all right
um hey that's a much gentler much nicer
we got a lot of feedback about the
timers how mean y'all there are to me
see okay good way to go America thank
you no we didn't get comments about that
we got comments about the timer okay yes
because it hurts my feelings go ahead
yeah that's what my concern is
all right I know you have feelings on
this one because we've talked about it
before should you be friends with
co-workers no just kidding
um
all right here's my thoughts on
co-workers and Friends yes you're gonna
work I mean we work so closely together
of course we're friends and I care about
folks and yes we're gonna have close
friendships
and
you gotta have people outside of work
here's what can be unfair
it can be unfair if your only friend
Community is your workmates and then you
come up with a personal struggle hey I'm
struggling with my drinking I'm
struggling with my mental health I'm
struggling with XYZ and you dump that on
a co-worker who then has to decide do I
want to stay employed here with this
huge secret
um I mean do I want to stay employed and
I've got to communicate to the
leadership hey this person's not fit to
be a nurse or a hospital aide right now
they're struggling with opioid addiction
or do I have to choose my friendship
over my personal responsibility my
ethical responsibility my work
um and keep this thing a secret that's
not it's not a fair position to put
somebody in so I can often hear like man
I can't believe you told I can't believe
you told so have some friends outside of
work that you can divulge everything to
that you can be honest with you don't
keep secrets from
um and yes have close close friendships
I just know I'm not gonna put Kelly in a
position to I'm not gonna come and be
like hey Kelly guess what happened this
weekend to where she's got to think
I might have to report this to my
supervisor because John shouldn't be
doing a show on marriage because he's
got 14 right right I'm not gonna put in
that position right I don't have trust
me
I'm not 14 anything 14 anything but you
did not always agree that co-workers
should be friends no I've come around a
little bit on it yeah that was the
minimalist had a lot yeah those two guys
are brothers and uh I've come around but
those two guys also have a level of uh
safety and understanding and Care
um if one of them came and said I had an
addiction Josh wouldn't fire Ryan be
like oh well you're not a minimalist
anymore maximalist right or if like Josh
bought a fancy couch he wouldn't be like
you're a fight like that's not how that
works that's not how their agreement
Works
um at most workplaces there's codes of
conduct there's lines you can't cross
and
um I think it's important that you don't
double down on secrecy because Secrets
will kill you
um and you end up with this double life
and it just comes out it always comes
out and it comes out in explosions don't
do it don't do it have friends outside
of the office too but but yes you're
gonna have friends people you care about
don't button we're for we're there for
life because we rock for life we rocked
that's all I'm saying
all right
I have a co-worker that doesn't have
good hygiene how do I say something
without hurting their feelings oh is
this about me no and I swear it's nobody
in this room there's Nate right there
I'm looking at Nate come on Nate
um I've had that conversation multiple
times in my career and it goes back to
that original thing you bring him and
say hey this is an awkward conversation
um I've gotten multiple requests hey let
me say this
if you have experienced somebody's not
showering you've experienced somebody's
body odor it could be cultural it could
be a homeopath there's always that
homeopathic person in the office it's
like I'm using crystals instead of
deodorant you're like we all can tell
right or whatever
um I just rub plants on my face and I
don't smell anymore it's like you for
sure do or I brush my teeth with
charcoal whatever your thing is oh gosh
the the the the toothbrush people are
coming for me it's cool man I've got
charcoal toothpaste here buddy back it
down a notch
um I lost my train oh if you've
experienced it don't call somebody into
your office and say
hey man a bunch of people are telling me
because when you do that people start to
think everybody's out to get them and
they're not be a person of integrity and
courage and say I'm experiencing
you've got extreme body odors becoming
very hard to work with you you gotta
take a shower you gotta wash your
clothes are you struggling financially
doing some help I've had one time I had
to have that conversation with a student
and their response to me was I can't
afford soap
and I said man we got you we've got a
special fund for that but they couldn't
afford soap right that's how they were
living so
um be Grace graceful and be um direct
and be kind and be on the same side of
the same team same team but one question
I have on that so the question is I have
a co-worker so is that something that as
a co-worker is that something that you
take to who doesn't want to know if they
have a booger on their face
or a humongous like white zit like
somebody hey will you tell me like I
want somebody to know I can something in
my teeth I would I would think less of
you as my friend if I finished an
episode of the show and I've got like a
huge thing in my teeth and I've got like
I care my friend tell me right that's
what I would expect that same as bathing
it had a little piece of biscuit today
and I told him I appreciated it yeah
because then I would be walking around
with that biscuit on my face and if
someone's talking to you like hey I
hard conversation real quick dude you
have coffee breath so much that I think
that you would knock down a small child
I want to know that I want to know that
I'm gonna brush my teeth I'll go with
some mints or something I just don't
want to be dragon breath guy the whole
day yeah if I've had something on my
teeth and I've talked to about multiple
people makes me so angry yes it makes me
think you're not a good human you're not
a good person exactly all right
um I don't think my leader leads our
team well right I've been telling Chris
that I'm just kidding go ahead
should I talk to their leader about it
the old end around
and I realized on a show that's often
about sex I shouldn't have said the old
end around
um
I reserve that's that's a nuclear option
for me I reserved that for ethical
violations and ethical dilemmas like
somebody's asking me to do something
that lacks Integrity they're asking me
to steal to cut Corners to change
numbers to whatever or I'm witnessing
this person themselves have unethical
Behavior they're fudging timesheets
they're they're whatever
um then yeah I will
um
in my life when I've experienced that I
have looked in the mirror and said what
if this can I tolerate and what if it's
going to not tolerate once or I think
twice I've left I've left I've chosen to
go because I don't want to work in this
environment other than throw grenades
because again that's just not who I am
um and other times I've I've been like
this particular boss of mine this leader
is just Bonkers and it's just the way it
is and I just put up with it when we
move on
so what do you think about that well we
have to hurry because I have a meeting
with your leader after this oh sweet
what do you think about that uh gosh
that's a hard one and
but I kind of agree I think that you've
you have to decide if you can stay
um but unless they're doing something
unethical
I just don't see a way that that works
out well if you go to their leader
um that's a hard that I don't see a way
that that ends well
if it's like that person's annoying or
that person's just rude or I don't agree
I don't like the way they're doing shut
up you know what I mean like I I decide
to be there don't be there right we have
to learn how to work in those kind of
because you're not everybody that you
work for is not going to be your
favorite person right and if that person
keeps making racist jokes that person's
that person's fudging the numbers yeah
we're gonna have another conversation
absolutely yeah all right
um I run a meeting and two people in the
meeting don't get along it's awkward for
everyone else how do I handle it you
call those two people in a room and say
hey we're grown-ups we're not children
we're gonna solve this problem right now
in fact I'm you don't need me to leave I
need to know what's going on here
because this is affecting everybody else
and if you all too can't get this
together y'all are opting out of working
here you gotta go because I'm not gonna
have YouTube people disrupt this whole
thing
and that as a leader that's my job is to
call them in and and deal deal with that
situation that's great all right last
one what is the worst career advice
you've ever received Follow Your Passion
so stupid follow your passion
if that was the case I'd be raising
unicorns like in Ireland something like
so stupid fault actually that's not my
passion at all I think
um I think that's just poor awful stupid
misguided
follow what makes you feel good that's
so stupid
um
most people most of the time become
passionate about what they're really
really good at and you only get really
good at something when you do it over
and over and over and you practice it
and you get lots of reps in and you fail
and you get back up and you go and most
of us only practice something that hard
when somebody's pushing us whether it's
a boss or a coach or a parent
and so ultimately you go all the way
down that line most of us are really
passionate about the things that we do
and the things that we're good at
because somebody made us put us in
uncomfortable situations along the way a
few people I've met them will Rudder is
one of those guys he just sits in his
room and jams that guy doesn't need
somebody yelling at him you need to
practice he just practices and he's one
of the best guitarists I've ever heard
ever in my life ever
um most people I know don't have that
they had parents that made him take
piano and take piano and take violin and
whatever and then they became oh I'm
good at this and then when I play it he
or she smiles at me I'm gonna keep doing
this or this teacher high fives me and
I'm gonna get better I'm gonna get
better and then all of a sudden they're
rocking Balboa bands
not quite like dumb button but they're
still rocking
that's all that's it that's it that was
it oh my gosh we are solving problems
here on this show we are definitely
changing the world Listen be a good
leader and if you don't know what you're
doing good entree what's that
reignsolutions.com entree leadership
check them out we'll get you they'll get
you you get your mind right when it
comes to leadership hey we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as you wrapped up today's show
I didn't know you were gonna talk about
this Kelly Kelly like right under her
neck in Old English across the top right
by her collarbone has this I need to
come up with a new font for my tattoos
because apparently they're all enough
English that was so is so is the name
Kelly on the back of your Eldorado that
you drive around and that Cadillac that
you have that pink one that drives I
really really like the old English
um font that's your thing Man it started
with that one Thug Life tattoo and it
has never you've never stopped getting
them yeah never look back it's weird
when she's not wearing makeup and it
just says Huey Lewis and the News across
her collarbone but alas her favorite
song working for a living here she goes
like she's got a hard job by the way
you're producing a YouTube I am tough I
am tough I'm sorry it's like hurting
cats people feel hard hurting a lot of
one one cat some days won't end ever and
some days pass on by I'll be working
here forever at least until I die damned
if you knew damned if you don't I'm
supposed to get a raise next week I know
Kelly won't working for a living
taking what they're given because I'm
working for a living
let's be honest none of us on this show
are working very hard
but you are we'll see you soon love
y'all